all right princess what would wait for
version from Florida Florida and tell
anybody shop did you grow up with both
parents one here um my mom and a stepdad
yeah it was great he's great uh-huh
well you fairy tale because I love drugs
is your favorite um heroin and crack and
what is you I'm doing heroin me like
five years I went swimming crack two
years
25
verging on the street you staying at the
hotel well I'm on the street but my
friend broke his legs so I'm just taking
care of him here I work the street
sometimes dangerous job okay I'm sure
you've seen some crazy stuff oh yeah
probably anything you could probably
imagine has happened to me give you a
story I've been kidnapped
I've been raised I've been everything
uh-huh you take a look in his car and
then he took me to like this sex Hotel
and then it was really [ __ ] up and
take to a hotel I was gone
hey like three days huh yeah I'm
completely honest and open with him 100%
and what do they say every day they
begged me to come home or good rehab any
of you busy yeah
why do you think
one time I did on my own and a couple
times I went to detox one time my mom
did it with me no no she's like lady she
just like laid in bed with me tell you
detox out the heroin you're dying
oh it's the worst thing in the world
you're you're so like I feel like you're
like a sick for however long at one time
I got clean in jail however long you use
it for
you're like majorly sick like dying for
like Oh week or two the thing you still
have the the goosebumps the chills up
your spine just to feel normal
no just a sick feeling or how good it
feels
attractive young female like you decides
to date guys for money paper for K kind
of what goes through your head when you
first probably when you first decide to
do that is it just like you're just so
jonesing for a fix that you just can't
yeah
thanks drew you just really don't care
you don't care yeah it's the fastest
easiest way to get money
yeah yeah right becomes an easy decision
yeah and the guys are generally okay
most of the clients most of them are
cool yeah most of our cool well I
normally don't date black guys unless
they're really old because they'll
either like try to be pimps or play
games or you know and I'm not saying
it's like it could be all people but you
know what I mean it's mostly Mexicans
and we do search for men almost 40 bucks
out here oh yeah
when I first came out here I was doing a
back page on the Internet I was getting
200 an hour I was in Burbank but all
those places and I was making Bank like
that I'm not sugar daddy but he decided
to put his hands on me for the first
time so I left him he was a
multi-millionaire but I he still calls
me this day and I was still won't answer
yes thank you